[Music]
hello and the welcome to dear Hank and
John or as I like to call it dear Emily
and hate it's a comedy podcast for two
brothers and sometimes just one brother
and special guest answer your questions
give me TVs if I serve you although
excuse from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
and today our special guest host our
guest not John John is Emily graslie the
chief curiosity correspondent at the
Field Museum in Chicago and host of the
brain scoop and Natural History expert
and etc
Emily how are you doing I'm doing good
how are you I'm good I'm good I'm angry
well I have a Hank I have a anger in my
soul because well Katherine and I a year
ago when Oren was four months old we
went to the Netherlands and we went to
the keukenhof gardens in the Netherlands
beautiful like basically a showcase of
all of the best tulip breeders in the
world and it's a beautiful place that
sort of makes me marvel at the ability
of humans and we bought a bunch of tulip
bulbs from the tulip breeders there I
don't think of the tulip breeder is the
right word but whatever that's what they
do they breed tulips yeah and and then
they sent them to us and then we planted
them and then after five years of living
in this house suddenly the deer have
found us and they are only eating the
Dutch tulips and not any of the normal
like Home Depot things we got that are
all over the yard but they have
selectively chosen to eat the and maybe
this is why maybe this is why the Home
Depot two hoops are the Home Depot to
upstate that maybe they're just not as
tasty is the good good they're basically
like Dutch tulips are like hot dogs too
dear
yeah I think these dear have champagne
tastes like that's right they know that
you've put in all this effort and energy
to bring these wonderful tulips back and
they think that it's a gift to them the
native deal Montana is there a gift to
them they thought how I should think of
it yeah they can't get doesn't
they're not gonna go they have no land
bridge that they can take advantage of I
think I've been fantasizing about like
cuz we can like I think I know when the
deer are showing up they're showing up
at like five o'clock in the morning
because occasionally I'm awake at five
o'clock in the morning and I can see
that there are no deer prints in the
snow and then there are deer prints in
the snow and so I'm thinking about just
like hiding in the bushes and then
jumping out grabbing the deer and
killing it with my bare hands but you're
saying that I should think of this as if
I I am doing a salted for the deer and
this is part of a it's part of like a
cultural exchange program in which deer
get to try new kinds of tulips yeah yeah
yeah and it's all about framing man you
know it's just just reframe the
situation in your mind and then you can
every morning just think oh the deer are
so grateful there look at how grateful
they are for what I have done for them
yeah yeah they eat half the tulip and
then they move on to the next one
because you know they want to try every
every individual tulip right you could
say you're welcome oh you liked the
orange ones well me too so that that
makes two of us no well I don't know
what color they are because they haven't
even gotten as a tulip part of being
tulips yet leaves how are you getting
tulips already we have snow oh we have
snow too
there's snow on our tulips those are
some resilient tulips well maybe I mean
they seemed very healthy before the deer
ate them well yes they light a life cut
short well I'm sorry I'm sorry your deer
and tulip problems yeah I don't even
know like I don't even feel like the
bulbs can come back from this anyway
you're probably not too much of a tulip
expert you you have a number of areas of
expertise but but other other than my
struggles are things going well in
Chicago aside from it not being tulip
season yet yeah well I mean kind of in
that vein I'm a little I'm a little sad
this week I had to cancel my vacation
that I was going to or tomorrow because
I had a plan to take a five and a half
hour road trip to go witness this giant
snake migration in southern Illinois
Oh J and like and there will be no
snakes in my future
oh so the just that you had to cancel
the vacation not because of anything
what to do with you but to do with the
snakes snakes aren't gonna come out no
they'll be too chilly it's so but can't
you just wait until it's warm and then
go I can but you know when you have your
heart set on something it was gonna be
it was gonna be March 5th I was going to
go on this intrepid voyage to go find a
migration of danger noodles and now it's
not happening and did you mean April 5th
just to be clear yeah did what did I say
May March March I was like I was like
you got a month girl just chill no it
was gonna be tomorrow okay anyway my oh
we're going in May so I shouldn't really
be that upset about it I'm just so wait
May is a long time from now is there the
danger noodles gonna wait that long to
come out
are they gonna come out at all I'd like
just you should just have somebody down
there like like waiting or like a nest
cam setup so that you can be like oh
there we go let's go what's going on oh
no no it's better yeah yeah like what
they like kind of what they do with the
the the blossoms the cherry blossoms in
DC I need like an indicator tree version
of that for a snake yes but it should be
a person who has my cell phone who can
call me at a moment's notice and be like
Emily danger noodles you know Emily my
Emily my clothes are covered in snakes
Emily they're everywhere Emily they're
inside of my mouth I'm dying
Emily there's a there's a venomous snake
coiled around my legs and I need medical
attention maybe that's not how that
should you know they're so hungry
they're eating each other Oh God
humanity but at least there's no snow so
come on down yeah so that sounds very
cool ah but the snakes are gonna be okay
they're not like in bad shape no I think
they'll be fine they're just gonna
probably wait to come out so so they
kind of from what I understand I've
never actually witnessed this great
snake migration there's like a a
limestone or sandstone shelf in this
National Park where a bunch of them over
winter and then it starts to warm up and
they're like hey it's time for me to
make some snake babies and then they all
kind of come out of these cliffs and
start to disperse and they just have
I'll cross this one road that they've
actually named snake road so so we were
gonna go down to snake road and just
hang out and just watch the snakes come
across there and they are venomous like
they're they're obnoxious takes there
are cottonmouths there are rattlesnakes
so it was gonna be a smorgasbord of
danger noodles and just regular noodles
frankly danger noodles and cuddle
noodles yeah and and little poops you
know just everything just everything
happy just snakes eat snakes cuz it
feels like if you just overwinter it and
you're like well as a whole lot of
snakes around and some of them are quite
small yeah I mean this trap that I come
in I think about that sometimes when
snakes eat things with legs like that
creates some some protrusions right
right yeah so if you can you just eat
another snake it's just like eating a
noodle just goes down easy so why not
well yeah yeah it's like pudding it's
like putting a cup into us a larger cup
it just fits right in yeah it's like all
the way down like a Russian nesting doll
of snakes snakes maybe that maybe that
snake had eaten the snake earlier and
you ate the snake and cuz you're a snake
and it's just yeah and then you end up
in a museum and someone's like oh we
have a boa constrictor and then they're
like no we don't we have a boa
constrictor that ate another snake that
ate another snake yeah it's like a
turducken but it's just thanks yeah I
feel like this is not offering any
dubious advice - no I mean you gave me
dubious advice for either the deer and I
appreciate that it's all about my
mindset more than how to prevent the
deer for meeting the tulips that's very
very good very dear Hank and John of you
yeah do you have a poem for us Emily I
do and the funny thing is when I thought
about bringing a poem I realized like
abundantly how not well read I am when
it comes to poetry oh yeah there with
you shel silverstein yeah yeah yeah I'll
get that but but I thought I'd be a
little bit more sophisticated so I asked
a friend of mine if they knew of any
poems about animals cuz I like animals
and so I have one from Lord Tennyson
called the eagle of fragment and this is
how
it's six lines it's very short he clasps
the crag with crooked hands close to the
Sun and lonely lands ringed with the
azure world he stands the wrinkled sea
beneath him crawls he watches from his
mountain walls and like a thunderbolt he
falls oh then this is kind of neat I'm
in the animal poetry that could be that
could be a thing I could get into yeah
he did another one called the Kraken and
that's 15 lines but we can save that for
a note for the future but that one is
also very good
you guys could everybody could just go
look it up and tell them Utley what'd
you think of the Kraken yeah that one's
got a little bit more drama so highly
recommended all right well and now we
have entered into the portion of the
podcast that is the podcast part of the
podcast where we answer questions and
try to give some dubious advice and the
first person that we're gonna do that
for is named Carina who asks dear Hank
and Emily is it selfish to want to be
cremated
since you're not really going back to
nature and stuff would I contribute to
the planet somehow by just being turned
into ash pumpkins and penguins Kareena I
think that we like okay Emily what do
you know about burial processes well a
little bit more than I then I knew
before I was on YouTube actually there's
there's this great creator named Caitlin
Doughty she's got a YouTube channel
called ask a mortician she is in fact a
mortician and one of the things that she
really advocates for is for green
burials and all sorts of like different
ways of sort of disrupting the the
burial industry so she's kind of a she's
a disrupter I would say and so she's
illuminated a lot of new ideas for me
about how one can return to the earth
and you can let you can be buried in
Joshua Tree so like that's a lot like
that's people like it's open yeah I mean
I think there's a permitting process
there's an application process and I
think it's there I mean there are
limited numbers of spaces but
increasingly there are more and more of
these green burial opportunities
cropping up with people thinking like
well why don't you just instead of
injecting me with formaldehyde and all
these preservatives you know just let me
decay naturally
in like a cardboard box or like a birch
box or something and then like plant a
tree and then when I die you all of my
bits can go back to the earth and
nurture bugs and stuff and and then I'll
just turn into fertilizer and then there
will be a healthy tree and I think
that's absolutely the what a wonderful
holistic way of thinking about it yeah I
mean the thing karinna to note is that
the traditional way of being buried you
don't become that useful because there
are you do sort of get preserved
eventually you get you know like all
your you know it happens but like the
the process is very slow when placed
inside of a very processed lacquered
hardwood box and inside you yourself
have been filled with a lot of things
that are designed to make you not decay
and and like that's the whole goal is to
make you not is to make the make you
look like you still alive yeah to make
you not be fertilizer and like I do I
think this is a very personal decision
for every person I think that there is
something good about cremation in in
that like you're just not taking a lot
of space oh you get to go where like a
place that you like without needing a
permitting process I don't think that
anybody needs a permit to just get
scattered somewhere also burial at sea
we did discuss that on a dear Hank and
John once and you do in a lot of places
have to get a permit to be buried at sea
but it is a thing that you can do which
I did not realize it's pretty amazing
that I think yeah I think that we have
to rigid I rigid an idea of what host
life disposal looks like and and I'm
excited for people who are trying to
think about that in different ways yeah
I mean it's like we there are logistical
space problems with everybody if
everybody who has ever lived or ever
will live is going to be in addition to
this being like pretty unaffordable for
most people like going into a coffin and
then into a cement
block in the ground like we're just
gonna run out of space so yeah well
there's I listen to a 99% invisible
about this recently it was very good in
which it is discussed that it is kind of
a uniquely American idea that you get
your burial plot forever that you'd like
this is where I rest and I will be here
until the Sun explodes yes in other
places you lease it and like when you
strike when you or your family stops
paying the lease they just put somebody
else down there that makes far more
sense yeah because then it's like 200
years from now someone's gonna show up
and be like well I guess I could have
put my grandma here but there's someone
here that we don't really remember
nobody's I don't know so nobody's coming
nobody's coming by yeah yeah who do you
really need this face right now right
you don't have any of it and that's like
that we don't want to think about that
that time eventually when people aren't
thinking about us anymore but that
doesn't mean that we didn't have an
effect on the world and that effect
doesn't ripple on through people who
don't remember us do you have any other
questions yeah yeah I I agree I think
there are lots of thoughtful ways you
can think about what is gonna happen
with your body I kind of you know people
have asked me would I be taxidermied I
feel like that's no I don't want to go
there no it may be an anatomy lab I will
not yeah that is people have done that I
think I can't remember some philosopher
is taxidermied at some famous school in
England and I'm just like no no and he's
like I don't know if he's on display but
he used to be at least and I just know
thanks there's an anthropologist who
passed away I think he he was he's
taught at University of Oregon or
somewhere in Oregon somewhere on the
west coast and he also was a big Bigfoot
believer and I don't know why that's
important to the story anyway
he ended up meeting some anthropologists
at the Smithsonian in DC and he had kept
all of his his Irish Wolfhounds when
like all of their remains after they had
passed away because he also was a big
fan of Irish Wolfhounds anyway long
story short he when he died in his will
he wanted to be have his skeleton
articulated with one of the skeletons of
his beloved dog and and now they're
still on display and you can go see him
with his his giant dog with its its
doggy paws on his skeletal shoulders and
there it is it's Smithsonian yeah well
good what's his name I don't remember if
you if you google Smithsonian skeleton
Greyhound dog it'll probably come up
it's a greyhound er I wish full found Oh
Irish well found cheese I'm good I'm not
getting my dog breeds anyway I'm looking
yeah his name is Grover Krantz and
very--it that's a big dog it is a big
dog it's a good boy too
yeah he's feeling a real good boy yeah
so uh that's cute yeah I kinda like kind
of like that I wouldn't mind that okay
yeah yeah more of it yeah you wouldn't
mind being an articulated skeleton you
don't like the idea of being taxidermied
yeah I mean I agree with you deeply I
don't know why that that feels so very
different to me but it does okay this
one this questions from Emily dear Hank
and Emily how do you throw away a trash
can do you put it into a bigger trash
can what about the big ones you put by
the side of the road our trash cans just
immortal one of many Emily I feel I feel
like this really goes into the
conversation we just had about snakes
eating space well then also uh what do
you do when you die what do you do with
your trash can when it dies I'm sensing
a theme yeah we you need to you need to
respond like take it to Joshua Tree bury
it three feet down not so deep that it
won't decompose yeah put it plant a tree
on it and then put a snake in it I don't
know I had this problem recently
actually I had like a like one of the
metal garbage cans
now that rusted out the bottom and and I
put it into a larger trash can and the
trash people took it
out and put it next to the trash can
basically to say no no no no you are
doing that wrong and I was like but I
don't know how to do it right so it's
just a mega rush so is it could it be a
recycling could you put it out on
recycling day maybe well I may maybe I
would assume like it's a hunk of Steel
like it's got to be useful to somebody
right yeah yeah do you what's wrong with
it
it's the bottom the bottoms all rusted
it oh oh you said that I was gonna say I
have giant aluminum cans full of
birdseed in my backyard so I was like
you but bird seed in it but if the
bottom doesn't work then it's not
functional you know maybe you should put
it out like upside down so that they can
they can see that the utility of this
particular job it's broked suggests to
emily is like maybe you need signage
there right yes in fact this wikiHow
article suggests putting the trash can
upside down and then if that doesn't
work putting a sign on it that says
discard or please take this or this is
broken have a nice day I hope that
things are going well with your family
the wiki how article says that yeah and
then the the final option if that
doesn't work is to cut the trash can up
with a saw and kitchen knife and put it
into a bag I feel like that was more
like that was someone's final attempted
they're just frustrated they're like I
can't handle it and then they just
angrily go to the garage and get a
chainsaw and start hacking it up and it
ends up working yeah time for the
machete yeah and then they also suggest
recycling it if you can figure out how
to do that so probably that's what I
will end up doing is figuring out how to
recycle it cuz it is I think a big hunk
a good steal why not someone could use
that yeah melt it down yeah you got it
turns to turn it into something else
make it into a birdhouse I don't know
metal birdhouse sure something put put
your snakes in it I don't know yeah
protect your tulips with it yeah yeah
make it you could
hammered out real thin and hand makes
some chicken wire
maybe I should protect my tulips with it
maybe I should just like stake it down
onto the ground around my tulips and the
deer won't be able to get in and then
like some sunlight will get in the rusty
bottom but then they like this the deer
will be like I'm gonna try to get my
head in there and it's like nope rusty
edges not happening oh man see Hank
you're still thinking about it like like
it's not a gift to the deer now you know
you're making an obstacle course I am I
don't I mean I feel like I don't yep
that's correct
I want to see my tulips I want my wife
to be happy about the tulips that we
have yeah well I mean yeah I also want
Catherine to be happy with with the
tulips so situation the tulips valuation
okay well if anybody has any suggestions
for how I can deal with these dear
without without murder please let me
know this next question comes from Matt
who asks dear Hank and Emily I recently
moved in with my partner it's both of
our first times living with significant
others and it's scary and weird and
exciting and really amazing the advice
I've been given pretty much has all been
compromised is key which is proven to be
true however a situation has presented
itself that I don't know how to
compromise on he doesn't organize his
books in any particular order on the
bookshelf he says he does not feel a
need to do this do I organize it for him
do I ask him to do it do I move out and
end our relationship this message
transmitted on 100% recycled electrons
Matt I
I feel like this went to a very extreme
solution without well without me and it
could have it could he could have
thought maybe like let's just burn the
whole place down that's just yeah like
maybe a book shouldn't exist anymore
let's end it all yeah but Humanity isn't
worth saving
there's a very simple solution here that
that isn't real I mean it is sort of a
compromise it's not even much of a
compliment why don't you just have your
own bookshelves so that I don't know
that that will
save the worry here there may be some
amount of like I can't have an not
organized bookshelf in my home Oh see
well buddy she don't say the bookshelf
but also it may not be a place that is
big enough for more than one bookshelf
but yeah it says the bookshelf which I
assume I assume that means you're
sharing a bookshelf and to me yeah I
think Emily you're right either two
bookshelves or just organize the
bookshelf yeah I more you just have your
own shelf on the bookshelf right how
many books are we talking right here
right oh well I don't I don't know but
but I also think like organize you your
boyfriend's books that's okay right I I
wouldn't mind it mm-hmm like if if to me
my bookshelf is in no particular order
that means I don't care what order
they're in so if they're in an order
that is equal to be as there being no
order oh I I just I feel like just to
each its own right I mean if he's fine
with not having books organized then you
just organize your books and just let
him have his books be disorganized cuz
that's part of who he is as a person
someone who does not care about the
organization of their shelf I mean I
guess yeah to your point if it doesn't
matter one way or another then there's
no loss but this is also coming from so
my my partner and i have very we have
our own bookshelves because we cannot
stand the way that the other one
organizes their book really fact yeah
you know he has made his own book plate
so he's so he's so thank you her about
about making sure that his his books
have his name in them that he has his
own stamp made and and that's fine
because it actually so then I don't have
to stamp on my books I just know that
the unstamped books are mine and the
stamped books are his all so they're all
on his bookshelf
his books because we we don't we don't
we don't share our books on one of their
shelves it's very rigid
he's his is very rigid of yours is less
rigid your systems I think yeah I mean
because I don't again I
really care my books are all over the
place and and I don't put my name in
them but I mean I do like if you are
merging book collections and it's not it
is a relatively early relationship I
would suggest a certain amount of
labeling might be good or some some
system of knowing whose books are who's
we catherine and i for a long time had a
lot of two copies of the same book
because our collections merged and we
were like well i mean i don't know i
don't know where this is going like
maybe someday we're gonna want to have
my copy and your copy and it's like like
three years into marriage before we were
like you know we probably don't need two
copies of this book yeah you probably
will probably add any it's safe to say
unless both we must need the same book
at the exact same time that you could
probably probably you know just hit that
yeah if we're gonna have to if we're
gonna have to divide the books up
there's gonna be bigger things to deal
with that won't that won't be the main
concern right yeah
but bob you're right i mean that's kind
of a add an early point of a
relationship
what like nat who had just moved in with
their partner you know that is that's
that's a big commitment
i don't know if that's conversation that
maybe they're ready to have yet yeah i i
organize my books by sort of kind of
book like i have a science fiction
section and graphic novel session and i
like a young adult section and like
nonfiction but it like eat within those
sections is basically wherever i you put
the book i don't feel like i have enough
books to need to do it differently than
that really I organized my books by how
much I liked them what so that's awful
like but like what if somebody comes
over it that that wrote one of the books
well if I will be like oh interesting my
book is at the bottom right what's why
is it what what's your ordering system
well it should also go hand and hand
sort of like the books that I really
like usually are from people that I also
know so I can't imagine it's
area like maybe the the author of of the
biology textbook fifth edition that is
on the bottom shelf of my bookshelf
maybe at some point they will take
offense to to the fact that I have put
that book down bombshell but I don't see
that happening
for instance you don't you know John's
books are on the top shelf because if
John came up I'd be like look John books
debate right they made it here they are
I enjoyed them yeah like my yeah that is
also my my chemistry textbook is also on
the bottom shelf sitting there being
like you know maybe someday you might
need this you don't know yeah but you're
like it's probably not gonna be I mean
the internet exists right yeah well I
mean what I was reading crash course
chemistry or like working on crash
course chemistry I I did open that book
a bunch but it's been a while since I
did that yeah so the utility isn't quite
there but I do it because if someone
comes over and they're like him I need a
book to read it's just easy for me to go
I'll pick one on the top shelf they're
all good right this the top shelf books
yeah yeah gotta be the name of a book
star top shelf you know that's not
that's a that's a good idea
top shelf books yep it is it's a virtual
bookshop what how does that work there's
not even a physical top shelf come on
well I mean if it was an actual
bookstore and only the books on the top
shelf were any good or there were only
books on the top shelves that would just
be a huge waste of space that's true
well maybe there's a cafe tearing up the
the other spaces from all the other
space yeah anyway hey hit me with
another question Emily okay this one's
from Elizabeth with with an S dear Hank
and Emily my best friend raises pet
chickens in Seattle while being a badass
woman can we say badass yeah okay well
being a badass woman in computer science
we Skyped yesterday and our chickens are
teenagers ugly teenagers I know we all
have awkward phases but I was wondering
which animals in your esteemed dubious
opinions have the worst adolescent
awkward phase any awkward chicken phases
in your lives not your mayor Elizabeth
Mayor with it I mean okay I want to see
some awkward teenage chicken so I've
googled that awkward teenage chicken I
think there's a night fold those are
cute they're like almost well it's the
thing where they're like they still got
their chick fluff but then they're
getting the feathers that's like oh you
look like I don't know you look oh
they'll that is look not well they kind
of look like they've like they've been
in a windstorm mm-hmm because life is
still there but there are some other
real feathers coming I mean it's exactly
what I look like in middle school like
like you've been through a windstorm
yeah exactly and but it kind of had
weird long legs and looked a little
frazzled on top right yeah no I think
that that is generally the catherine was
saying on delete this our our podcast
last week that there's sort of a faith
that you go through when you just turn
into a bunch of noodles and like you
like your arms like your arms end at
your knees and it's like what's
happening why did this happen and why
are like you skis and you do you're like
one of those those wind dudes outside of
car dealerships yeah just constantly
getting blown around like I don't know
what to do with my appendages yeah yeah
and like and then just breaking things
both both inside and outside of your
body there's a there's a lot of damage
happening damage occurs and which made
me think that the most awkward juvenile
animal I'd seen is maybe a young giraffe
which is just all all made of knobby
Wiggles yeah yeah there's just like a
tiny little nucleus of a body and then
the rest is just sticks everywhere like
so much going on these things so but so
cute though yeah the awkwardness is
pretty endearing at that level I was
thinking
the worst adolescent awkward faces
probably also I should preface this that
it's it's kind of gross but it's true
Magus Matt gosh Emily aren't the maggots
the juvenile phase themselves yes and
and they get so wrapped because if you
because they're just baby flies and if
you if you think of a baby fly then you
know there's something maybe endearing
about that terminology but there's a
double standard here Hank and it's
because people love caterpillars which
are the right right the adolescent
stages little wormy decent Butterfield
just a maggot butterfly yeah and but but
people give fly babies a bad rap and I'm
just I'm thinking of double standards
here that's great it's a great point and
I mean the thing the thing of it is like
it's not like they grow up and they
become beautiful majestic creatures
though like I agree that I'd rather like
be in the presence of well no no of a
maggot like what would I prefer to be
hanging out with like 20 maggots or 20
flies I don't know at least the maggots
are staying in the same place mostly
yeah yeah
you know I think flies are kind of
inherently beautiful too especially if
you see some like nice macro photography
but that also requires that they are
still and usually dead Oh interesting so
I I'm just I did you know personally I'm
also like not a gigantic maggot fan I
think it's because of the the quantity
of numbers in which they're usually
found mm-hmm like a little they're like
because if you found a bush with like
three million caterpillars on it that's
also kind of disturbing right yeah well
at least now we get to know that but of
that caterpillars are ruined for
everyone now that I have the phrase
butterfly maggot in my head I I had very
strong opinions about this when I first
read that question and I didn't exactly
articulate them out loud and now that
I've gone down this route I'm I regret
it a little bit
I mean yeah I well I think that I think
that all larval forms are pretty awkward
adolescent phase and I sort of like the
quintessential awkward adolescent phase
in in children's media because it's
always like the the caterpillar is very
hungry and he gets a stomach ache in
that he's a beautiful butterflies that
is the story I wish dive into me Lauren
it did look at you you used to be a
windswept noodles and now you're Emily
graslie host of the brain scoop but I'm
still hungry Hank I'm always hungry
alright yeah you didn't stop being
hungry yeah but are there any other
animals that have awkward Tina I feel
just like that it's a really uniting
it's a ignites all of us yeah
teenager Tim is a really a really
interesting phase of awkwardness I think
that dogs have really great awkward
teenage years oh so good so good do you
do you go on the subreddit blender years
no bunker years is good oh good thing
it's so good
it's so it's it's just for people who
don't know it's blender years and kind
of like Wonder Years but it's just
pictures of people from their most
Awkward the points of their life ever
it's it's amazing this subreddit brings
me so much joy yeah I mean the the nice
thing about like when I was that age I
didn't realize how awkward I was I
didn't know it
no and that's like the beauty of it is
like you're so blissfully unaware of
yourself in context of your surroundings
of you know your self-expression isn't
quite on point and and you just don't
even know until ten years later and you
look back and you're like oh dear why
did my mother let me walk out of the
house like that yeah I as a father now I
think about like I will just have to let
him walk out of the house like that
there's nothing there's nothing else I
can do about that no I like you can't
control them no no and you don't even
want to because
I think at that point if someone's if
they're not even listening to you right
like there's maybe that angsty teenage
phase that I think many of you guys have
been it you're just kind of like you
know what fine just go you just you can
you can recoil in disgust at yourself
ten years from now when you see your
picture on the top page of blender years
and I I will just look forward to that
moment and it's all fine the top the top
picture right now is this kid who
covered himself in armor made out of
connects I mean that's a win now yeah
yeah it's a it's truly delightful okay
okay Emily this next question comes from
Andrew who asks dear brothers and also
Emily I took a summer class on ecology
and we had a class on invasive species
my question to you is this are humans
invasive species if humans are should we
have global regulations on our movements
I know that there's not a way for this
to actually happen but your podcast is
pretty nebulous so I thought you were
the best people to talk to Seth I
thought you're the best people to talk
this out all the best even in death
Andra alright Emily are humans an
invasive species I have lots of thoughts
go oh this question makes me so
uncomfortable because I know yes yeah
yeah yes yeah it really yeah it deeply
depends on the definition what I've
learned from living in Montana is that
invasive species is an ecological term
that is is understood mostly in terms of
economic impact so we talk about
invasive species particularly ones that
like cows can't eat that's a big problem
when you have a species that a cow is
like nope I'm incapable of digesting
that they become very comfortable on the
rangeland and then suddenly you have
lots of plants that are not nourishing
your cattle and you have you have land
that is less economically productive
than it once was
same thing with like zebra mussels that
cling to
boat propellers and hydroelectric
systems and you have to scrape them off
and turn off the the dam for a little
while while you do that and it results
in lost money so in this weird way it
turns out that we of the this this
ecological problem that we understand
and we discuss through an ecological
lens in reality when we talk about it
it's a human economic problem that we
actually when we actually sort of are
working and spending money trying to fix
it I never thought of invasive species
in that way yeah it's totally like like
living in Montana you start you get a
real good look at that if you if you pay
close enough attention because it's
really all about rangeland and yeah and
not about like preserving the the
ecological diversity of a place right
and that's I mean that's really
interesting because when I think about
invasive species I think there are a lot
of like ideological lets you know things
that we can the these Narnia's that
don't exist these gardens are eaten that
are never going to return to a pristine
habitat and and by wanting to eradicate
everything that's quote invasive about
it is really just sort of like a
colonial of approach to right an
environment and so I feel really
uncomfortable with the idea that someone
could say that humans are an invasive
species because then what we're where
are we and where are we supposed to go
who are we displacing or who right who
are we advocating for the displacement
of and I really don't like that way of
thinking about it right no I like I told
yes it's a and it's also I mean the
entire idea of an invasive species of
exotic invasive like these this doesn't
happen I mean it does but it almost
always happens because of human
intervention and of course there is
something different about people that is
different from nature but the way that I
tend to think of it is not like okay you
have this box over here that is human
and you have this box over here that is
nature and you have technology and you
have the biosphere and they are sort of
like opposing but very separate sphere
is I have I have been able to understand
it and like keep this like sort of an
internalized understanding that I don't
have to like refresh in my brain it just
like it stayed with me that the biology
is in us and we have this extra stuff on
top of it but like the biology will
never come out of us and and technology
is a biological product in the same way
that biology is a chemical product and
and just like we have by chemistry
inside of us we have biology inside of
us we have evolution inside of us like
that is all part of our story and who we
are and and I think that there can be
this weird like purity argument that
comes out of our feelings about nature
that is really kind of fake yeah that
that stuff is always changing and it's
always in disruption and in fact what we
find in ecology is that disruption
actually is like not just the natural
state but also where a lot of diversity
comes from and that you don't have like
single like wide swaths of old-growth
forest you have mixes and meshes and
that mixi bit like where it's not the
same everywhere is actually where the
most interesting nature happens yeah I
think there's a lot of really
interesting things too that are
happening with especially with science
communication about how you know certain
things have in the past been demonized
in a way that isn't necessarily fair so
if you think about like bacteria right
and there's a big proponent that have
everything germ-free which is Terry
Terry you don't got what to be germ-free
germs are your friend number one and two
we did a video about this a couple of
months ago but the ecological importance
of parasites I think there's there's a
tendency don't want to eradicate any
idea of anything living and feeding off
of you or your livestock or anything but
it turns out that like parasites are
kind of like the NIST's they're
necessary in a way that a microbiome is
necessary and so I think it's kind of a
fun way of looking at the world if you
if you imagine not that there's anything
pristine to aspire to but more
understanding like
the role of everything is currently
playing in the current structure and
having a curiosity about that so I don't
know that doesn't really go back to the
question about our humans and invasive
species I guess technically maybe but
also is it helpful to think about humans
as invasive species because I'm not sure
that it is right yeah I mean I it
understanding an accurate understanding
of the relationship between humans and
the biosphere is very hard to like I
don't think that there is one I don't
think that there is like one right way
of thinking about it but yeah I think
that the the thing that's necessary that
has been necessary for me is an
appreciation of humans and sort of like
amazement at them in the same way that I
have an amazement at the biological
systems and to to appreciate both of
those things and know that like yes one
of them feeds off of the other more than
the other feeds off of it but but you
know we are remarkable and I want to
continue thinking and then I can add
like I think objectively that like
humans are extremely interesting and oh
yeah cool and and that oh that it's
almost like thinking you know like the
geology of the earth would be more
pristine if there weren't so many
animals on it
and I'm like okay but like you don't
want no animals there awesome right also
yeah what about the fossil record with
the fossil record is just the gifts on
giving and you're like yeah totally
what happened to the Cambrian this is
crazy this is crazy
alright I want to do one more question
before we get to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon and I would like you to
ask this question about salt because I
think it feeds into this conversation
we're having yes this is from from Tessa
dear Hank and shrimp and Emily I guess
I'm a big fish you have it do you do you
have an adolescent nickname because that
was John's out of us a nickname oh oh my
adolescent oh god my adolescent nickname
was Emily P and I mean that's not a good
nickname
but it but it's the truth which is what
matters right I hated it and my sister
insisted on calling me Emily P and I
don't know why and but it always
bothered me and so she kept doing it
because that's what older sisters do
perfect
so dear Hank and Emily P I am a big fan
of the pod and a need of your dubious
expertise I recently started thinking
about salt namely sea salt and why
people always make a big deal about it
being sea salt doesn't all salt come
from the sea I realized that actually
maybe since salt is a mineral it's also
possible to extract it from the ground
how does that process work and do we use
all kinds of salt in our food why is sea
salt seen as the best and most luxurious
of all salts many thanks in advance
Tessa I like the luxurious because it is
like that's it's a weird thing that like
we've created this like this marketing
machine around a type of salt to be like
it's not just salt
it'll taste salty yeah no it'll taste
like so but it'll just like it's more
expensive so it's probably better right
I mean this is this isn't just sea salt
I honestly
Hank and Tessa I kind of think that sea
salt is a little 2015 I feel like right
now we've moved on the rage is gray salt
and Himalayan pink salt even though I
would also say Himalayan pink salt is
more 20-17 than anything oh and now
there's gray salt what's what the Frick
is grace ultimately I've never heard of
this Hank get this it's salt that
happens to be grey why it's a grey
because they put like extra money in it
so it costs more or maybe it's just
dirty and they're like you know what we
are going to save a bunch of money by
not having to clean this salt so and but
well we'll just marking it as grey salt
and people eat it up literally grey salt
so I look I'm looking up grey salt right
now oh god it's it's favored by chefs
100% natural salt whatever the free
you are you know god it's just rocks
it's just rock an article on livestrong
calm gray salt versus him alone I mean
there's an entire this article is far
too loved it has opinions it's not like
actually it's just the same as the
normal South of you you so I mean I know
that there's like there's just more
minerals than this other stuff so if you
just so there's a lot of salts as is
what we call it an any ionic compound in
chemistry we call a salt and there's a
lot of salts in seawater and the most
plentiful one is sodium chloride which
is what is in table salt and when you
make table salt because you're like
people want the thing that they want not
a bunch of extra stuff mixed in because
it's the 50s and we want to make things
that are the things people want rather
than like the most weird natural we're
not even sure what's really in this
which is apparently the crazy degrees
right now
you make it pure sodium chloride so they
go through with some processes to make
it pure sodium chloride now they put a
touch iodine in so that people in
America don't get goiters anymore and
that's table salt and it comes from
mostly from mining salt but mine like
when you mind salt that also usually
came from sea salt or from inland seas
like the Great Salt Lake where there
were long periods of time where water
was going to a place and then
evaporating and then that got covered up
with rock and then you dug it out and
actually interestingly one of the ways
that they do this is instead of digging
it out with scoops they'll pump hot
water down and then they'll pump the hot
water out and the hot water will come
out with a bunch of salt in it and then
they evaporate off the water and you get
the salt and then what's left behind is
a giant hole in the earth where there is
nothing because you've pumped all the
salt out and then sometimes occasionally
and there's a video of this happening it
just collapses and like all the trees on
top are like soup and just fall inside
there's a really great video of all of
it like an entire swamp falling into one
of these salt caves that they made
pumping salt out of a place i I don't
know if I don't know if you could find
it just by googling like salt cave tree
falling
faster or something salt cave tree fall
disaster what do we get
video gotta type in video yeah yes there
is a video that comes up there a video
but it's not the video I'm looking for
really oh yeah by you by you corne
sinkhole swallows stands of trees it's
really good it's it's like three minute
long video and the whole time you're
like what's happening are those trees
really gonna fall into just like they're
just gonna keep falling oh man everybody
look up the Bayou corne sinkhole and how
they're there they go they're just there
trees and then they're just where are
they going where that's they're not
falling over they're just getting the
weight they're just going down and then
they're just gone they get sucked away
and the trees are gone now and the guys
with the cameras just sitting there and
I'm like how do you know that's not
gonna happen under you right now right
Hank can I just I am so impressed by how
much you know about salt
I was not it not at all anticipating all
of this that I feel like we really
touched on something that you feel
personally very invested in right well I
guess I may have I may have a strong
opinions about a number of things that I
shouldn't have strong opinions on it may
be one of my one of my vices I but I do
feel so and then when you make these
other kinds of salt are just the raw
salt that hasn't had the other minerals
the other ionic compounds taken out of
it and and so that has more stuff than
just the salt in it which I don't like
maybe some experts can taste the
difference between those things I don't
think that you can because salt is a
very strong flavor and and they aren't
it is definitely not like healthier for
you if you want to get extra minerals it
makes a lot more sense to just get those
minerals rather than like loading it up
inside of your food by making it saltier
which has potential negative health
effects right I mean in this this
article that I'm still amazed that there
are so many words to compare grains and
Himalayan pink salt I mean they do go
into nutritional profiles and
differences in texture and use so I
would say some people do have strong
opinions about that I don't know if
those are based out of science you know
what I want to I won't and the next salt
trend that I want to see happen mmm I
want everybody to just go to salt licks
just just a salt lick on your table yeah
just choose enough part of the salt lick
and sprinkle that on top no no no no no
no no we gotta go straight to the source
you eat a bite of your food and then you
lick the salt yeah you bite your food I
lick the salt
yeah can we make that happen and
everybody like everybody just passes the
salt like around me like hey can I get
the salt cuz I'm a freaking deer like
I'm like an elk yeah yeah I really feel
like I mean why not great
how weird can we make this you know I'm
probably guys offended some chefs just
now or just people who are really into
their special salts but I in general we
had it we had a question that we didn't
end up asking last week that from
someone asking I was told by my barista
that I was gonna that she was gonna make
me the best coffee I'd ever had in my
life and I was like I don't want that
cuz then like all the other coffee won't
be as good forever and I was like yeah
kinda like maybe I just don't want to
know how much better the expensive salt
is maybe I just want to keep using the
salt that Kate that costs like literally
nothing it's like basically free because
of how much you can get for how low a
price right Abbi I don't want to know
maybe I don't want to know like how much
better a thing is and it went honestly
like it's probably not that much better
I just want them I just want my coffee
that I made in my house yeah I mean it
right we're just feeding into this
culture of always needing the the bigger
better more delicious salts I don't feel
like that's sustainable for people today
think it's too much are you sure oh god
it's so much pressure how like do I have
to choose what kind of salt I'm using
right I can't just like do I have to
feel like weird
bad about using normal salt yeah because
then you're gonna have a dinner party
and then and then you're you will so
your it's a scenario where you went to a
dinner party at someone's house and they
had a Himalayan pink salt on the table
and then you invite that person over and
then you realize that you you uncultured
you know the plebe only a regular table
salt to offer your friend who has much
more sophisticated tastes than you do
and then and then what do you do with
that then you're gonna feel
self-conscious and oddly inferior for no
reason other than this weird precedent
that we've said that everybody needs to
if you can afford it than have fancy
table salt everything has to be fancy
which reminds me Emily of our sponsor
this week which is uncultured plebe salt
it's our new product it's just salt it's
it's like one cent more than the extra
salt that you can get from like the salt
people but our salt is made by us so but
it's called uncultured plebs salt and
it's just you can feel okay about using
normal salt oh geez I think our other
our other sponsor for today is turducken
snakes for when one snake isn't enough
you need a snake ception so get your
turducken snakes it snakes all the way
down yes we also have a project for
awesome message from we also have a
project for awesome message from rod
reran to Natalie Natalie sorry Natalie
who is her favorite sister I miss living
close you should come visit we have two
pita pits in a ten-mile radius
I will even let you sleep in a bed that
is definitely mine with whatever that
means if we have to share it you could
have the edge and I'll take off my socks
we can stay up late playing skip-bo and
boggle it'll be like old times
love your favorite sister that sounds
nice and sweet yeah I feel like there
were a lot of inside jokes the in there
that I didn't understand but that is
yeah but I'm but I'm for it
I'm for it with skip-bo the one with the
thing that goes on your foot yeah okay
right
yeah I think so it's a skip poem boggle
are two very different kinds of games
but I like Lee he's got both physical
and weight no skip oh is it is a card
game it's like it's like uno but
different oh yeah skip it the things you
put on your foot what happened to those
you know what I they probably got
recalled because I remember playing that
with my sister and if that thing flies
off your foot it's going 20 miles an
hour right in the face of the second
grader in the in the yard one over
that's what happened to that that's
right
Oh God or people just started using them
as weapons
Emily kidding the deer with them to stop
them from eating the tulips we've got
some news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
today I think that the the
responsibility for both of those News's
has followed on my shoulders today and I
have good Mars news and bad AFC
Wimbledon news familiar you like deeply
curious about what I'm about to tell you
yes let's start with the AFC Wimbledon
news absolutely humble didn't now I
believe I think so they lost their game
this week they lost despite basically
having a great opportunity to not to not
lose in that they had like seven corner
kicks to the other teams one and they
had the most of the possession and they
had most of the shots on goal and and
yet still in the 22nd minute of the game
the only Gore was scold the only goal
was scored by the other team whoever
they were and that that means that AFC
Wimbledon is now I think that it's the
bottom five that gets relegated I tried
to Google this but I wasn't good enough
and fast enough to do it and if it is if
it is the bottom five than they are at
the tippy top of the relegation zone
just above the as John says franchise
currently applying its trade in Milton
Keynes whatever that means and and so
it's possible that both AFC Wimbledon
and that the franchise will both end up
getting relegated and will be playing a
m-- League to once more together and
that would be a real bummer but at least
MK wouldn't stay up while AFC went
so but there is still time left hey if
somebody needs to win games by scoring
goals and if they can do that then they
will be able to stay in Ligue 2 or
League they will stay in Ligue 1 and
continue playing soccer with better
teams than are in Ligue 2 and I maybe I
don't know make more money somehow and
that will be that will be good for the
team and the fans they just have to be
better they just have to be good then
just I think that what would help is if
they would score more goals and have
fewer goals scored against them yeah
that's kind of what I took from took
away from that yeah better defense and
offense yes better at playing the game
good better soccer and we we also have
our modest news folks I don't mean to
mock AFC Wimbledon I just
that's all I that's all I can tell you
we have a proposal out of NASA to design
robotic bees it's what they're calling
them that can fly on Mars what they
announced the project March 30th so just
you know last week and it is in its
early stages but the idea is to replace
Rovers with a sort of station that like
stays in the same place it's like a
charging station and communication
station and the bees fly off do stuff
fly back to the charging station and
then they recharge and they can like
dump data or something and or even
samples maybe and then go back off and
fly around even more and the these
things are little so they would be like
literally the the body part would be the
size of a bee and then the wing part
would be bigger than a bees wings
because there isn't a lot of atmosphere
on Mars yeah they got a fly and they
they'd fly around on Mars like yeah
doing doing weird science and this is
very cool there are lots of places that
like Rovers can't get to easily and it's
dangerous to take a rover into a place
where the sand might get it stuck or it
the the grade is too steep
but flying thing wouldn't have as many
of those problems and if even if it did
land and then fall over maybe you could
figure out how do I get itself righted
and back into the air again sure and and
also the sort of like there are there
could be lots of them and so if like one
stops working you got backups so this is
actually an idea that that NASA is
floating and working on and trying to to
engineer a lot around a little bit to
see if maybe it's a potential future
Mars mission I I have a I have a
question okay so why why call them B's
and not just flies well so Emily I don't
know if you know this but people like
bees they make honey and they prevent
the world from starving to death and
flies are annoying and we killed them
and we see them as unsanitary baguette
machines I know I just I was trying to
get back to my point about about this
ridiculous bias that we have we do we do
it's lies I'm just it's a recurring
theme not just in this podcast but in my
life no Emily talked to me when a fly
makes something that I eat regularly I
aren't fly aren't some flies pollinators
I believe they are no no no no I mean
like delicious sweet sugar sauce that I
put in my coffee
it's like that's magic that yeah I mean
I don't think that flies vomit
sweeteners that is true but yeah let's
do lots of great work and there are many
different types of flies that and and
only some of them are the ones that end
up in our homes are bite us up man a
horse fly I hate a horse fly I cannot
abide they don't have very many friends
but to get back to to the point that is
the Mars news is that's cool but did you
ever think that we live in a time where
you're talking about sending tiny little
fly BOTS or bee BOTS
to to Mars no I did not and and like the
you know the scope of curiosity in the
Mars 2020 Rover is so outside of the
scope of Rovers when I was you know
first started getting excited about
space exploration that it's it's kind of
easy to be like Oh a rover is a rover
but it's very different to have like
this like thing that's the size of a
dinner plate basically versus the thing
that's the size of a car moving around
and doing now over 2000 days of science
on the surface of Mars curiosity is the
coolest great what a great name for for
it I'm surprised that that one had was
available still right like they had that
wasn't on the top five like back in the
sixties right yeah that's like well
we're gonna name these ones Spirit and
Opportunity because we're saving
curiosity for when we send like
basically cars right but what an amazing
time to be alive right and you can also
get whatever the Frick kind of salt you
want I know the the world really is your
oyster your salty salty pink Himalayan
salt II oyster gross Emily thank you for
making a podcast with me today what what
did we learn do you remember I feel like
we've been all over the place I feel
like we learned that it's okay to have
your ashes spread in the ocean with a
permit I feel like it's okay to be the
sort of person who just wants basic salt
in your life and we also learned that
butterfly maggots are just caterpillars
and also that Emily has a favorite
subreddit in which this guy is wearing
Kinects armor and it's real real good
and I'm proud of him yeah I am too he's
he's being the best version of himself
and and I support it
and we support it Thank You Emily this
hang up and thank you everyone for
listening this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and shared and
Gibson our a head of community and
communications this Victoria bon giorno
who also runs our patreon she could find
it patreon.com/scishow Hank and John it
has a number of opportunities including
you can listen to our dumb podcast where
we talk about people called this week in
Ryan's and and that money goes to
support all of our shows that we make
like scishow and crash course and
healthcare triage and sexplanations all
that cool stuff and if you like what we
do here you can check that out you can
also find things that we'll post on that
patreon that is available to everyone
whether you cannot support it or not as
well thank you all very much if you want
to email us you can do that at Hank and
John at gmail.com and we are on Twitter
at Hank green and at John Green and
Emily is also on Twitter at Mei hme
Thank You Emily for joining us and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]